c'est une épreuve de vie qui m'a
enseigné l'optimisme depuis je crois à
l'intelligence de la vie quelles que
soient les aspects qu'elle prend à la
base moi je fais sinistre mes parents
m'ont appris pour mon bien qu'il fallait
sérieuse en toutes choses que tout était
important aucun set permanente de ma
part immunisé des problèmes nîmes à
protéger face à une réelle épreuve
le jour où un accident a pris une partie
de mon apparence physique il partie de
mon visage j'ai été placée dans un tel
état de déprime ans qu'il ne servait à
rien de lutter je n'avais que à me
laisser conduire parce que me proposait
la vie
bienheureux les fêlés car ils laissent
passer la lumière
et depuis c'est cette lumière cet
optimisme que je place au service des
entreprises que j'accompagne et les
futurs psychanalyste psychothérapeute
que je forme lors leur premier rendez
vous avec un patient je leur propose
cette phrase qu'est ce qui vous fera
dire que vous n'aurez plus besoin de moi
cela permet au patient de formuler une
situation déjà résolu et de se tendre
inconsciemment vers l tel un arc quelle
audace
imaginez la raison pour laquelle la
personne consulte est déjà résolu
et vous c'est comme dans la chanson je
me voyais déjà en haut de la fiche vous
prenez maintenant une situation
difficile
qu'est ce qui vous fera dire qu'elle est
résolue
qu'est ce que vous voyez
qu'est ce que vous entendez
qu'est ce que vous ressentez garder
cette image et ses ressentis car ils
vous serviront tout au long de votre
parcours résolution cela rejoint une
lois quantiques selon laquelle
l'observateur modifie l'expérience c'est
fort
si je modifie mon regard sur la
situation jean modifierait l'issue si je
m'oriente de tout mon être vers une
situation
alors je lui donnerai les chances
d'advenir avez vous entendu j'ai dit de
tout mon être et pas seulement avec donc
avec mon corps qui ressent qui perçoit
et pas seulement avec ma tête qui
prévoient qu'ils gèrent qui anticipe et
c'est là où est toute la difficulté de
l'optimisme qui ne se décrète pas qu'il
se capitalise pas on ne peut que lui
dire oui et s'ouvrir à lui une épreuve
comme un divorce un licenciement
un accident est toujours une rupture par
rapport à ce qui était prévu
quand dans ma vie parfaitement bien
réglée est intervenu le choc de
l'accident
je n'avais rien d'autre à faire que de
me laisser porter et en disant oui à ce
qui venait ça ne servait à rien de
lutter contre l' événement parce que j
aurai perdu mes dernières forces et lire
oui même si ça fait mal même si c'est
insupportable ce n'est pas du courage
c'est juste qu'il n'y a rien d'autre à
faire dire oui à ce qui y est fonctionne
également au quotidien
les choses ne se passent pas tel que
vous aimeriez qu'elles se passent d'un
grand classique
oui c'est rageant mais imaginez deux
secondes à l'enfer si nos vies étaient
régis par la cacophonie de nos égos
respectifs dire oui à ce qu'il revient à
s'effacer au profit de l'intelligence de
la vie et souvenez vous ce n'est pas que
ma volonté soit faite
imaginez je vais très mal je suis au
fond du gouffre et en plus je dois être
optimiste
non l'optimisme c'est léger ça procède
d'un allégement donc enlevons ce qu'il
entrave a plutôt que de se rajouter une
exigence de plus d'ailleurs les
personnes souhaitent souvent plus
d'énergie pour avancer être re motiver
rebooster redynamiser alors qu'elles ont
déjà besoin de desserrer la [ __ ] du
frein
plutôt que de chercher à appuyer sur
l'accélérateur dire oui à ce qui y est y
compris à notre part d'ombré
les théories newedge élude très
facilement notre pardon bat pas
seulement nos gros défauts mais les
parties de nous parfaitement inavouables
si vous les ignorez
rassurez vous l'épreuve va voulait des
vignes et les intérêts de l'épreuve
c'est qu'elle sollicite en ou départ
profondes celles auxquelles on n'aurait
pas accès dans l'ordinaire et le
paradoxe autant la difficulté ou les
preuves ne place dans un grand sentiment
de solitude parce qu'il n'y a que moi
qui puisse me lever le matin autant en
puisant mois et à l'intérieur de mes
ressources
je me sens particulièrement relié à tout
ce qui m'entoure et aux autres
si je prends l'exemple des sept nains de
walt disney en moi il ya une personne
timide qui doute une partie fragile une
partie qui sait tout de la life
si je fais le tour de mes sept nains de
mes sept gros défaut de mai cette
petitesse et que je les accueille avec
tendresse je serais capable de faire la
même chose avec les défauts des autres
avez vous remarqué que lorsque vous avez
fait la paix avec votre grain chaud
interne les râleries des autres vous
énervez nettement moins de la même
manière
pensez maintenant aux traits de
caractère de quelqu'un qui vous
insupporte
bravo vous avez gagné 1 à un terme à
aller voir et à aller au sol et car vous
ne pouvez voir chez les autres que ce
que vous avez déjà en vous
d'ailleurs les héros des comptes ne sont
jamais seuls
ils font toujours accompagné de plus
petit que des nains des valets des
animaux et à chaque fois le sens et le
même fait équipe avec les pas négliger
de vous même celle que vous dévalorisez
et voyez le résultat
vous souhaitez être optimiste et bien
cultiver la joie le plaisir de faire
pourquoi pas savourer des mains que vous
êtes déjà en haut de la fiche savourer
dès maintenant que le problème est
résolu
comment croyez vous que j'ai préparé ce
talk to mon été en anticipant le plaisir
que j'allais avoir maintenant à partager
ce contenu très dense avec vous
l'épreuve appellera chemine
et aperçoit un groupe d'ouvriers en
train de travailler
que faites vous bah ça se voit on est en
train de construire un mur
le pèlerin poursuit sa route et aperçoit
un autre groupe d'ouvriers dans la même
situation mais plus joyeuse cette fois
ci et il leur pose la même question
nous sommes en train de construire une
cathédrale
moralité même les actions simple humble
du quotidien porteuse de sens sur le
long terme
utile à d'autres génère de l'optimisme
et diffuse autour d'elle de la joie
une épreuve est un signe anthologique
d'élection elle nous choisi pour révéler
notre grandeur quand dans la gestion des
conséquences de cet accident
je me suis ouverte le plus possible à
ceux qui étaient en recherchant le plus
possible l'alignement
j'ai réalisé rétrospectivement que la
vie m'avait beaucoup plus donner que ce
qu'elle m'a des prix sur le moment en
anglais blessures et bliss ont la même
étymologie une blessure comme une
bénédiction
cela ne signifie pas qu'il faille
cultiver la souffrance pour mériter un
accès au bonheur mais que la douleur est
un signe émis par notre être profond
pour plus d'alignement
l'être humain est le seul à être debout
son corps forme à un axe entre le ciel
et la terre et il est également le seul
à avoir un privilège de conscience ce
qui lui donne un sacré devoir
d'alignement de cohérence entre ce que
je pense ce que je dis ce que je fais ce
que j'aime et qui je suis
et le sens de l'épreuve est simple elle
nous remet debout dans notre bon sens la
kz2 l'humain et vertical face à
l'épreuve
il peut regarder vers le bas à
l'intérieur de lui et se demandait
plutôt que d'accuser les autres où le
contexte qu'est ce que j'ai fait pour
comment je me suis pris pour
bref en quoi je suis responsable ou co
responsable de ce qui se passe en
anglais il ya une très belle expression
responsble en assumant la responsabilité
ou en recherchant ma responsabilité je
deviens capable de réponse si je ne suis
pas responsable de l'événement qui
m'arrive
alors je suis responsable de latitude
que je choisi d'adopter vais-je ajouté
de l'appel à la peine
où vais-je m'orienter vers une situation
de résolution de transformation l'agse
l'humain est en vertical dans l'épreuve
il peut regarder vers le haut à la
recherche du sens y compris symbolique
de ce qui arrive est de passer du
pourquoi au pour quoi en deux mots
une fois l'épreuve traversée nous sommes
grandi renouveler alignés et
complètement rincé
elle a fait tomber tout ce qui est est
obsolète
sans destruction pas de régénérescence
et ça c'est très difficile de le faire
admettre qu'il faut faire le vide pour
faire le plein que le plein de nouveaux
est proportionnelle au vide consentie et
que les preuves nous aide bien malgré
nous à faire ce vide
pour autant quand on fait ce travail en
recherchant l'alignement ou à accueillir
le plus possible ce qui est qu'est-ce
que l'optimisme est généreux il octroie
bien plus que ce que l'on espérait notre
héros des contes non seulement à
délivrer la princesse ce qui était pour
lui un but élever mon jeu tombe
amoureuse de lui et les poudres jamais
au départ il n'avait tablé là dessus
avec tous ces gros défauts se sentait
complètement insignifiant mais son
parcours plein d'audace et de courage
la récompense est et c'est exactement la
même chose au niveau interne
quand je fait équipe avec mais non quand
j'embrasse mon crap ma grenouille ce qui
est et l'est devient charme et j'accède
au royaume de mon humanité profondément
en lien avec le royaume de l'autre de
vous autres non
oui il est difficile de rester droit
aligné dans les épreuves et les
difficultés mais la recherche du cadeau
cachée de ce qu'il ya de bon pour vous
dans la situation même si vous ne le
savez pas encore vous en or à lorient
quand vous serez désorienté et vous
regarderez là vers où le soleil se lève
toujours et depuis cette nuit depuis
cette soirée
je vous souhaite une belle journée